how's everyone doing tonight so I love
this new format because when they called
me to ask me to participate they said I
want you to tell a story and I'm like oh
my god I get to salt or tell a story and
not a PowerPoint this is so awesome so
I'm going to tell a very personal story
and one that's very meaningful to me and
one that actually taught me a lot in
life so it's all about immigration so
who in this room is an immigrant are
born from foreign parents immigrant
parents awesome I think that looks like
75% of the room so that's that's awesome
I too AM born from immigrant parents my
mother is Mexican and Japanese but born
and raised in Mexico City if you buy
Latino and my dad is is French American
born and raised in Los Angeles in East
LA so this story specifically is about
my mother who is my role model my rock
with force she's taught me so much in my
lifetime and I think this story is worth
sharing as a result so my mom my dad met
in Bangkok Thailand of all places my dad
was leaving the Navy after four years
and he was stationed in Okinawa Japan
and my mother was traveling to Japan for
the first time in her life she was one
of 12 in her family six boys six girls
and she was the first one to be able to
save up enough money to go visit her
family in Japan so she actually got to
meet her cousins and her grandparents
and everything so she was the lucky one
of the 12
so she was 19 years old very young at 19
and she went with two of her girlfriends
to not only Japan but Singapore and
Thailand and in Thailand as the princess
Palace and
in Bangkok she met my father and my
father went up to her and said buenos
dias senorita without knowing anything
I've done it those words she's like who
is this strange man in uniform
approaching me he says I have to see you
again
like I can't not live my life knowing
that I didn't try to see you again so my
mom's like well I'm in this little tour
group and it was a very official tour
group the one with a little flag and
he's like I don't give a I'm gonna
go find you wherever you are and he was
he showed up in her hotel and my mom my
mom is very conservative and she's like
okay well if we go out you have to take
my two friends too so my dad like the
poor guy coming from the Navy has like
20 dollars to his name really spent his
last 20 dollars on these on these ladies
but he didn't care and he said I just
wanted to be around he wanted to be
around my mom and get to know her better
so he said before he left I will have
three packages waiting for you in Mexico
City and a letter and on this day they
will arrive and on that day they did
arrive and my mom's like okay this guy's
serious I think he likes me
and and he ended up going to Mexico City
a month later and just trying to get a
job with his very little Spanish and
just wooing wooing my mom and and he
couldn't find a job so he went back to
LA but he's like I miss her too much
through the back three months later and
try it again and actually started
meeting the family which is a big dealer
in Mexican families and cut to six
months later and
married so it was accepted into the
family very surprising given that my dad
my grandpa's a Shinto priest Japanese
like doesn't you know didn't want her to
marry someone from another race which is
a little bit ironic but the things that
my mom learned when she came to the
United States she's both very little
little English and she was taking a lot
of risk coming to the United States
without her family without her loved
ones without a job with a man that she
only knew for six months I mean this is
a stranger really and she was also nice
teen okay I mean like that's a crazy
decision knowing that in retrospect so
she she said I knew that this was the
right thing for me I really wanted to
take this risk he was a man of integrity
he is a man of integrity and so she
moved and again learning Spanish really
trying to understand English really
trying to understand the language and
learn the language fast so she could get
a job and she did get a job she was
working at she got a dog working for
Mexicana Airlines which is no longer in
existence and she was working at their
corporate offices and she did well and
she was there for 15 years and she said
this is sort of a piece of cake
like I can actually run my own travel
agency easy so she did she opened up her
travel agency and it was in Southern
California and then she opened up a
couple different offices started getting
huge groups of clients that would come
to her groups of people people that
would come back and put groups to travel
packages together things like that and
she did really really well she made a
lot of dough
and she actually ended up making more
money than my father who worked at the
Walt Disney
opening and ended up putting my sister
and I through college and my sister went
to UC Berkeley I went to UC Davis so na
and so having a role model like my
mother who sacrificed so much
emotionally financially physically to
come to this country and be resilient be
boot bootstrap be scrappy not take no
for an answer and just yes I know I can
do it I know I can build this business I
know I can make money I know I can make
a living
she taught me so much and this whole
point of being a start-up entrepreneur
going on finding your passion and
purpose and building a company has a
deep connection in correlation to being
an immigrant right I mean you have to be
scrappy 51% of the 51% of the most
successful startup I think it's the
billions the US dollar billion dollars
from startups are actually built by
immigrants so that's a really amazing
stat and yeah
and the resiliency factor the fact that
she was always saying you know you can
do it you can follow your dreams you
know we had it really difficult but here
you have resources you have a community
you have people to to answer your
questions you have advisors you you know
you have really great educational
institutions and organizations to
support what you're doing so you you
really don't have an excuse okay so I
think that's what she taught me is this
really really be be scrappy you can do
anything that you put your mind to
because there's people out there that
have it a lot harder than we do and you
know just think things like an immigrant
be like an immigrant because I think in
the end you'll be very very successful
and resilient and be able to accomplish
your dreams thank you
[Applause]